j'en parle avec notre chef de bureau ses
bassins c'est un constat brutal café
bernard drainville en fait il s'est
rendu compte que la deuxième place lui
échapper dans cette course oui appelons
ça le syndrome raymond bachand vous
rappelez de raymond bachand et de la
course à la direction du parti libéral
il partait deuxième sur la ligne de
départ il est arrivé 3ème au fil
d'arrivée ça a été une humiliation pour
lui alors probablement que bernard
drainville savait qu'il ne finirait pas
premier dans la course à la direction
mais ils espéraient finir 2e est
probablement que ces chiffres nous ont
dit qu'ils ne pouvaient même plus
espérer finir 2e alors plutôt que de
subir cette humiliation entre guillemets
il décide de se rallier ils évitent des
déchirements sur la place publique et il
peut prétendre à un poste important dans
un parti québécois qui pourrait être
dirigée par pierre karl péladeau
justement qu'est ce qu'il apporte à
pierre karl péladeau parce que c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui a de bonnes
assises dans le parti oui certainement
de bonne assise dans le parti la porte
peut être un peu d'expérience il a plus
d'expérience parlementaire plus
d'expérience de politiciens que pierre
karl péladeau alors ils pourraient le
conseiller là dessus il lui apporte
aussi un sens politique je pense vous
savez bernard drainville et de sept
cette trempe de politiciens qui est
capable de viser la jugulaire de ses
adversaires parfois démagogue sur les
bords aussi mais il est capable de dire
les bons mots au bon moment de passer un
message relativement facilement ce qui
manque un peu à pierre karl péladeau qui
se définit comme politicienne devant nos
yeux alors c'est un peu ce que bernard
avait elle peut apporter en plus
évidemment des cinq députés qu'il
appuyait cinq des sept qu'il appuyait
qui vont avec monsieur péladeau et des
militants qui appuyait monsieur de
révéler qui pourraient aller avec
monsieur péladeau également et en
terminant est ce qu'il reste une course
vraiment on a entendu martine ouellette
et alexandre cloutier dire que ils
continuent ils sont là pas encore pour
gagner c'est ce qu'ils disent est
aujourd'hui mais à quoi ça sert vraiment
ce sera peut-être avoir une deuxième
position et si on reprend l'exemple du
parti libéral rappelez-vous de pierre
moreau qui a fini deuxième à la surprise
générale et qui a un poste enviable au
sein du gouvernement alors peut-être
d'avoir cette deuxième place est un
incitatif à rester mais en même temps il
est peut-être des militants qui vont se
dire il ya un risque ces trois
prochaines semaines à se déchirer sur la
place publique et même des militants qui
ont dit à bernard drainville qu'il
n'aimait pas son style combatif ont
peut-être qu'on veut éviter les
déchirements peut-être que martin
ouellette et alexandre cloutier auront
de la pression eux aussi pour ceux d ici
tu es au fil de ces trois dernières
semaines de campagne à suivre donc merci
beaucoup sébastien nous a pris bonne
soirée